مواجهه اسود الاطلس مع الديوك في نصف
نهائي كاس العالم
كبيرا في الصحافه الفرنسيه
تطرقت الصحافه الفرنسيه للجوانب المرتبطه
بالمباراه من اداء المنتخبين في البطوله
والماضي المشترك والروابط الثقافيه بين
الرباط وباريس هذه المباراه ستكون الاولى
بين المنتخبين في تاريخ بطولات كاس العالم
وما عداها كان فقط مباريات وديه صحيفه
نموم قالت ان اسود الاطلس اخترقوا السقف
الزجاجي للدول الافريقيه وهو دور الثمانيه
او ربع النهائي الذي لم تستطع سابقا الفرق
الافريقيه تجاوزهم في نفس السياق قالت
صحيفه ان المواجهه تحمل امال القاره
الافريقيه والعالم العربي مضيفه ان وجود
جاليه مغربيه كبيره في فرنسا قد يشكل نوعا
من الحساسيه بين الجماهير اما صحيفه
باريزيا فقد نوهت الى ان فرنسا ستواجه
خصنا يكتب تاريخه بعد سنوات من الخيبات
واشارت الى ان الفوز على البرتغال في
الدوري الماضي لخص روح بلد باكمله
صحيفه
الرياضيه عن هنا عددها الصادر اليوم
الاربعاء بعبارات ثلاثه نجوم امام الاعين
في اشاره الى رغبه فرنسا بالفوز بلقب
عالمي ثالث سيكون الثاني تواليا انتحر
اضافت الصحيفه ان مهمه فرنسا لن تكون سهله
خاصه وان المنتخب المغربي صارم في كل
لحظات المباراه ولا يترك فرصه للخصم
للاختراق دفاعاته من جانبها قالت له
جورنال دو ديمونش الى المنتخب المغربي
فريق لا يستهان به وقادر على استغلال
انصاف الفراس
انه شعور خاصه
مغاربه مؤيدين لفريقهم وهذا شيء رائع
بالنسبه لهم لانها المره الاولى التي يصل
فيها فريق افريقي الى هذا الحد القريب جدا
من النهائي
من اجلهم ونمل ان تسيير الامور بثلاثه لكن
هذا لطيف للغايه لانها مع الجاليه
المغربيه هنا انها لعبه بين الاخوه الليله
سيكون خصوما في الملعب ولكن هذا سيتبعه
حفل كبير بالفوز